well I'm back everybody good to be back
and so much to discuss we'll start with
the situation in Russia a failed coup
attempt which Vladimir Putin has
survived but to what end and with what
long-term impact we just don't know but
let's go through what took place over
the weekend incredible uh the Wagner
group Wagner group everybody has their
own way of pronouncing it launched a
coup attempt by sending tanks and troops
towards the Russian capital of Moscow
hoping to overthrow Vladimir Putin and
put in some kind of puppet leader quite
frankly the mercenary group the Wagner
group is led by yevgeni pragosian uh
formerly a close associate of Vladimir
Putin's sanctioned by the U.S for his
role in interfering in the 2016 and 2020
elections and pagosian's alliance with
Putin Sauer Lord when he accused Putin
rather he accused the the Russian
defense minister of incompetence and
betrayal claiming that he had ordered
attacks on Wagner's troops in Ukraine
and elsewhere the timeline as far as we
understand it is that on Friday June
23rd pregosian threatened Rebellion
Saturday June 24th very early just hours
later one in the morning on Saturday
Vladimir Putin was briefed about the
armed Rebellion that was being
threatened by 7 30 a.m the Wagner group
claimed control over rostov military
facilities and the airport two hours
later the March towards Moscow began 10
a.m Vladimir Putin addressed Russia on
television calling the acts treasonous
and by that night 8 PM pagosian as far
as we currently understood understand
halted the march on Moscow the reports
are that the coup attempt was foiled by
the Bella Russian president lukashenko
brokering a deal between Putin and
pregosian allowing progosian to escape
to Belarus in exchange for some kind of
Safe Haven presumably pagosians failed
coup attempt also has shown shifting
public opinion about him and the Wagner
group and quite frankly the f Michael
dilemmas of supporting or opposing coups
based on who it is that is doing them
this is a critical aspect to the story
pagosian's coup attempt
had mixed reactions among both Russians
and the International Community when
news broke of this and in fact I have
some Ukrainian friends who with tears in
their eyes wrote out wrote to me and I
could tell even though they were texting
that they had tears in their eyes they
were happy about this they welcomed it
as a challenge to Vladimir Putin's of
course authoritarian rule
uh and the idea that maybe there could
be Democratic change in Russia others
condemned the coup attempt saying it's
Reckless it's a violent act that
threatens Russia's stability it
threatens Russian Security even if the
coup were to succeed it's it does not
set Russia and the Russian people up for
really dramatically improved
circumstances there are those who say a
coup is never Justified regardless of
the regime that they are targeting
because who's undermine the rule of law
they undermine the will of the people
others say well sometimes the rule of
law and the will of the people has been
undermined by the strong man who is in
power already and the coup might be the
only way to actually get back on track
these are the various opinions that have
come forward one position
is that it's okay to support coups if
they are against
undemocratically elected leaders can it
be said that Putin was elected
democratically well he says he was
there's this ostensible democracy but
was it Putin won his fourth presidential
term with 77 of the vote in an election
that was widely criticized by domestic
and international observers for to put
it lightly
irregularities and violations so is
Putin actually democratically elected
Putin's main opponents were either
barred from running or jailed or even
worse Putin's critics were excluded from
the vote unconstitutional reforms which
allowed Putin to reset term limits and
run for two more six-year terms that's
not democracy but does that mean we
support a coup attempt and then of
course the the other part of this is
that pragosian himself
initially seen by some favorably as
someone doing a good thing worthy of uh
the international left's support and
that very quickly came apart once more
was learned about pregosian and Wagner
group's activities in different theaters
around the world so uh that is where
things stand right now as far as we know
there is not total transparency about
news regarding exactly what is going on
but the broader and more forward-looking
question to which I just don't think we
have an answer if you Google what comes
next in Russia what happens next to
Putin you will find several dozen op-eds
from the last 24 to 48 hours no two
agree about what is coming next and in
particular for Vladimir Putin the most
optimistic sort of Blended scenario that
I've seen
put forth
is that now with the threat of the coup
but the coup having failed Vladimir
Putin May realize his days are numbered
and will engineer some kind of
face-saving exit from power to avoid
being deposed or whatever I just don't
know that that's really the most likely
scenario here so that's the latest we
have out of Russia as of this moment
we're going to continue following it
we'll probably have more for you
tomorrow or the next day if you've been
getting crushed in the markets lately
like many people have you were probably
happy to hear that treasury yields have
been surging right now you can get a
five percent yield on treasury bills
Which is higher than most high-yield
savings accounts I've seen and unlike a
high-yield savings account treasury
bills are a fixed rate asset so you know
what you're getting at the time of
purchase but buying U.S treasuries can
be very complicated or at least it was
because our sponsor public.com lets you
buy treasury bills in seconds right from
your phone and put your cash to work
keep in mind that treasury bills are
government-backed securities considered
one of the safest Investments around
when you buy them on public they are
securely stored at the Bank of New York
Mellon the world's largest custodian
bank and Security Services Company plus
there are no minimum hold periods or
settlement delays you can access funds
anytime if you keep it invested public
will automatically roll over your
Investments at maturity so you have one
thing you don't have to think about go
to public.com Pacman to start getting
that five percent yield on your cash the
link is down below